comment va votre moral de morale au
québec c'est plus l'homme aux héritiers
de la première marque pas en général est
bon mallet et commence à être tanné
on arrive toujours aussi faim pas facile
de garder le moral en ces temps
incertains
la deuxième vague est difficile mais les
résidants du grand montréal ne se laisse
pas abattre
73% des répondants au sondage de radio
canada assure garder un moral assez bon
ce port un mauvais chiffre n'est pas
catastrophique mais la réalité cache en
fait ce chiffre la cache des réalités
très différentes dans les sous-groupes
comme pour les jeunes quand même assez
de c
ces emplois en famille
a été du monde
j'aime juste emménagé ici je connais
personne lésée suscite l'école olympe
ccf en passe de peyton motivation je
dirais que c'est parlant des hauts et
des bas je pensais quand même si 86 %
des 65 ans et plus ont affirmé avoir un
bon moral
le taux chute à 56% chez les 18 24 ans à
l'adolescence on est dans le moment
présent
on a besoin de construire notre identité
on a besoin de vivre on a besoin de
faire des expériences justement y ait
beaucoup tous ceux qui leur sont
enlevées donc c'est pas étonnant que ce
soit plus difficile à vivre pour eux
difficile mais les résidants du grand
montréal font preuve d'indulgence et
adhère aux mesures sanitaires mises en
place soixante dix pour cent pensent que
les mesures en zone rouge vise les bons
secteurs 77% qu'elle ne brime pas leur
liberté
[Applaudissements]
quant à ceux qui croient fermement le
contraire ils ne représentent que 8% des
répondants la minorité qui est
insatisfaite et pas mal audible en tout
cas pas mal plus que ce que l'on voit
dans les chiffres même que 42 % des
personnes sondées seraient prêtes à
accepter des mesures plus sévères pour
moi c'est pas assez sévères parce qu'on
aurait dû
c'est comme vraiment faire une fermeture
pour vraiment laisser les choses se
calment et ma préférence qui est pas
d'halloween pour qu'on ait un noël
issigeac aubry charbonneau raid au
canada montréal